so
in here we've got a magnet that's
generating a very large magnetic field
so
we have to watch your camera actually
because if you go too close to that
magnet then it's just going to wipe the
tape what
because because mac tapes the tape in
your camera is is works using magnetism
is the information is laid down in in uh
by changing magnetization on the
magnetic tape so
if we go too close to this magnet in
here it'll just erase all the
information on your tape and you know
we'll have to start again so i want to
talk about b which is the symbol for
magnetic field now most people when they
think of magnets think of
something like this little fridge magnet
here what is that so that's that's
this has come off our fridge
so you can see percy the penguin there
is he's sticking to that piece of uh
steel
and
b
is
the magnetic field so this is what we
call this this is the sort of the
invisible lines of of force that come
out from this magnet i can i can just
sort of briefly draw
a diagram so if i
show this disc like that
it's a
almost artistic drawing in the world
with some arrows on like that
now the spacing between those those
lines so this is this is what we call b
so well
as with many things it depends what
astronomer you ask for example if you
ask an astronomer who studies the sun
they would tell you that magnetism is
really very important and in fact if you
look at some of those beautiful pictures
of the sun you can actually see the
magnetic field of the sun you can
actually see the streamers of material
being bent around by magnetic fields in
the sun so you can very explicitly see
it
are there any more are there any
stronger magnets what happens if we find
a stronger magnet and in fact just over
here i've got a these are
some of the
most
powerful
permanent magnets
that um
anybody's ever made actually these type
of magnets and these are called
neodymium magnets
i want i want to keep these two magnets
far enough apart because if i if i get
them too close they attract
oh they're so strongly
that it almost takes your finger off
in fact
they collide with such force that it
actually starts to shatter the magnet
okay so if you want to go much stronger
than uh one of these neodymium magnets
then you have to uh
use what's called an electromagnet now
an electromagnet is something that um we
can make just by
uh wrapping this is so this is a little
bit of copper wire here and i've made
this electromagnet by wrapping the
copper wire round and round around this
uh steel screw here if i if i bring this
uh steel screw up to the paper clip you
can see there's no it doesn't stick
there's no attraction to it
but now what i need to do is put some
electric currents i need to apply
electric current to this coil pass some
electric current through the coil
and i've got a battery a couple
batteries here and i just i'll just
stick that terminal on there and that
one on there and then there you go so
we've generated a magnetic field yeah so
if you can imagine scaling this thing up
passing more current through it getting
uh bigger turns bigger wires we can
generate much much larger magnetic
fields and it just so happens that i
have one next door so if you'd like to
follow me we can have a look at this
beast next door
for the most part astronomers try to
ignore magnetic fields just because they
tend to be rather complicated very messy
and because the things we can typically
measure in astronomical objects are
really rather simple we can only get the
rather crude quantities about objects
from the things we can actually see
magnetic fields are just too complicated
to really study in detail so
in here we've got a magnet that's
generating a very large magnetic field
so
we have to watch your camera actually
because if you go too close to that
magnet then it's just going to wipe the
tape what we've got here is is
some lines on the floor just marking out
uh the magnetic field strength so
um round about here we're approaching
something like
i don't know 10 times the earth's
magnetic field
so there's kind of this classic thing in
astronomy that we have you know research
seminars where somebody will give a talk
about something if you're the person
who's in charge of the seminar series
it's kind of expected that you'll come
up with a question at the end of the
seminar
and quite often you're kind of
struggling to think of something to ask
if you haven't you know if you really
haven't quite understood what the talk
was about so the classic thing to ask
you know at the end of a research
seminar is oh yes but what about
magnetic fields because almost certainly
the person you're talking to won't
actually have an answer because magnetic
fields are very complicated but you'll
sound quite clever because magnetic
fields almost certainly affect a lot of
things going on in the universe but just
a little level that's too complicated to
understand so so actually we have to
take some precautions when we go in here
we don't take our keys in there or don't
take the keys too close to the magnet we
have to make sure we don't carry our
wallets in there because
your credit card details are stored on
magnetic stripes on your on your credit
card so you go too close to the magnet
with your credit card it spikes and
actually that's happened to me once and
also um one key thing is uh if you have
any piercings as well so this can get
quite embarrassing you know if you've
got um you know piercings in your mouth
or in your ears or elsewhere you know
this will be strongly attracted to the
magnets and if you get too close it'll
just rip it out of you so i have to ask
these questions you know do you have any
metal in your body so you if you you
want to come this way and if you want to
follow this yellow and black line here
um through into this part here all right
so this is the this is this the giant
version of the electromagnet that i was
showing you earlier
is slightly different from the it's not
just a scaled up version of that
electromagnet it's what's called a
superconducting magnet
so
actually when i applied a current to
that elect that little mini
electromagnet with the orange wire
earlier on
when i apply a current it gets a bit
warm because the the wire has some
resistance to it
um and so actually if i leave that mag
that battery connected for more than a
few seconds is actually the wire starts
to get a bit hot it's dissipating energy
here we've got a superconducting magnet
so all the wires in it are
superconducting they're cooled down to
four kelvin so minus
269 degrees c and at that temperature
the the wires don't have any electrical
resistance to it so it means we can pass
enormous currents through it without
generating a lot of heat in fact it
doesn't generate any heat when it's
superconducting so i can show you the
size of the magnetic field around this
uh magnet if i bring my keys i don't
want to get the keys too close because
if i get them too close what happens if
you stick to the magnet if i just
if i just bring them a little bit
like that you see
see my keys
don't break my camera no no no don't
bring it over this line
this is my favorite bit showing this
yeah
well what you're basically looking at
there is a can it's a double walled
container
and inside that container um we've got
this we've got liquid helium at 4 kelvin
and inside inside this bath of liquid
helium we've got essentially one of
these
coils wire it's not an you know orange
covered copper wire but it's this
more expensive superconducting wire
and
the um the magnet itself is about this
sort of size that sort of diameter you
can imagine that that kind of thing and
we've got a hole that passes through the
middle
and
the whole thing is arranged so that
the hole through the center of the
magnet is at room temperature
so that the can has got like a hole
through punch through the center that
you can use to do experiments inside the
magnetic field inside this very very
strong magnetic field at room
temperature so we don't have to do them
at 4 kelvin well this magnet is
primarily used to do
magnetic levitation studies
and what we can do with this magnet is
we can perform
experiments that would normally only be
able to be done on the space station for
example or on
on these parabolic flights where they
take um jet airplanes up and uh you know
do these
parabolic dive bombs so-called vomit
comet flights